and then his point was i don't
understand why we're getting so much
hate look at all the good we did for
peasants in mexico
which is a little bit of a weird thing
to say when you trick american voters
into voting something and then
after the fact you say sure it may have
may have made some of you worse off in
ohio and michigan
but look at all the good it's good for
the other country yeah that we did in
nairo
so let me ask your view assume for the
sake of argument
that the objective is to benefit
americans in the united states to
benefit jobs to benefit their economic
welfare
to make their lives better in your view
what would be the optimum
immigration and or trade regime that
that would maximize the economic
condition for americans well
first of all it's a great question i
have
to show that i'm not there's nothing
xenophobic about this so i've written a
paper called migration for the benefit
of all
peer-reviewed economic paper about how
you can open a border ethically by using
cosy and immigration that is most
americans most valuable possession
is actually asymmetric access to their
labor market
and we don't realize that that is
actually the source of our wealth now
that
again but could you if you wouldn't mind
put that in layman's terms
sure you have the right to your own
labor market given that your co
your country maintains a right to
conscript you to tax you
yes part of the social contract is that
you get a share
in your country's wealth through having
a right
now the interesting part about it is if
we can just get your right
declared red tape or an impediment
to the free market then i can take your
right without having
to pay you anything for it now this is
in fact a violation of free market
economics
so let me ask what what does it mean to
have a right to a market i
understand something called labor
certification so when you
get labors when you have labor
certification you have to go through a
certain amount of so a high-tech worker
to come in there has to be a
certification that there's not
there are not u.s people to fill that
need yes and in fact yeah
uh we should not make labor
certification easy
because part of what forces us to renew
is putting our businesses under pressure
so what one of the things that i find
very interesting so i'm not going to say
something pro right
after i've been anti-writing yes i
because i just for for those who are
struggling to keep catch up as i am
you've just come out and criticized the
reagan era you've
you've uh built up your left-wing
bonafides he's criticized the reagan era
for too much big government you're right
which i'm actually perfectly fine with
that criticism
and then eric you've gone back and
attacked the left
for or at least i suppose we would call
it the modern left for its
open borders or advocation uh advocacy
of
high high skill immigration it didn't
advocate for high-skilled immigration it
lied
effectively what you did is you got the
national science foundation and the
national academy of sciences to stab
american scientists in the back on
behalf of scientific employers
and so all of the sloppy talk about best
and brightest
um you know so if tim cook were sitting
here tim cook would argue that they need
access to
to chinese and indian engineers in
computer science
never sit here if i'm on set
let's imagine the hypothetical or tell
me why you would have to chain him to a
radiator or you would have to wield
him we have those tools in this podcast
that's true
that's part of our hollywood setup here
but it's very important and it's one of
the reasons why people won't invite me
to talk about
i mean there is essentially no no one
uh at my level that i know of
who's openly against high-skilled
immigration is the worst part of our
immigration
yes this has struck me as a position you
can't say you can say it on things like
podcasts
which is why i think you have a
successful podcast and why people listen
to this show too and let's
segue this is fascinating but i i don't
want to miss a major portion of this
topic which is you and i told you we'd
get back to this
you made reference to to the modern left
to
to some or even many becoming maoist yes
and and and for the listeners i i think
i know what you mean but tell us what
you mean by that well
you have a very weird coupling on on the
on the
technical left so with dick morris
and bill clinton effectively becoming a
second republican party
you then had a problem with which is how
do i replace
organized labor labor as a voting bloc
and my wife pia milani's great insight
here
was she's an economist with the
institute for new economic thinking a
soros-funded uh institute now we've got
the left-wing bona fides again all right
i'm
reoriented uh her point was that you
need something cheaper than labor
because labor makes economic demand so
there's always a
search for who's willing to accept the
least and the thing that you can
actually get voters with
for people who are willing to accept
very little has been identity politics
so the idea is that identity politics is
the is the electoral
substitute for organized labor that was
lost
after bill clinton and dick morris
decided that you had to have two
republican parties in order to
not have more than 12 years of
continuous one-party rule
and one sees memos going around the
internet for instance from mega
corporations that that actually show
executives that some major corporations
have relied on identity politics
to divide up labor in the hopes that
they wouldn't union so